Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je vais vous parler d'énergie.
Sujet ô combien d’actualité.
Depuis des décennies,
la production d’énergie s’est développée
sur un modèle centralisé,
qui, aujourd’hui, est remis en cause
de toutes parts.
Et si la décentralisation était la vraie
clé pour une transition énergétique
afin que les citoyens deviennent
acteurs et parties prenantes
de la production d’énergie
sur leur territoire ?
Je m’appelle Valérie Sol et je suis
impliquée dans un collectif citoyen
de production d’énergies renouvelables.
Depuis sa création fin 2009 à Loubeyrat,
au nord-ouest de Clermont-Ferrand,
cette initiative 100% citoyenne,
sans but lucratif,
milite pour un modèle énergétique local,
afin que le sujet soit porté
par les territoires,
en regroupant des habitants,
des collectivités, des entreprises,
à travers des projets d’énergies
renouvelables comme le photovoltaïque
ou l’éolien.
Notre terrain de jeu se situe surtout
dans les Combrailles auvergnates
et descend jusqu’à
l’agglomération clermontoise.
Je me suis engagée dans cette initiative
voilà maintenant sept ans.
Au-delà d’une prise de conscience
grandissante sur l’écologie,
des gestes que je pouvais faire
dans mon quotidien,
à travers ce collectif citoyen,
j’ai trouvé le moyen d’aller plus loin,
d’exprimer mon pouvoir d’agir
dans le cœur d’une dynamique collective
en réalisant des projets concrets, utiles.
Même si au départ, au même titre
que les autres membres,
je ne connaissais absolument rien
aux énergies renouvelables.
Ce qui m’a séduite avant tout,
c’est que des personnes arrivant
de tous horizons professionnels,
animés par cette volonté commune
de vouloir faire bouger les choses,
se regroupent et ont l’audace
de proposer des projets techniques
sur leur territoire et de montrer
à tous que c’est possible.
Aujourd’hui, nous sommes propriétaires
de 23 centrales photovoltaïques
réparties sur une dizaine
de collectivités,
installées sur des bâtiments publics
et qui bronzent sous le soleil
des Combrailles et alentour.
L’électricité produite est intégralement
réinjectée dans le réseau public
afin que cette énergie verte profite
non seulement aux bâtiments publics,
mais également aux habitations alentour.
Ces 23 centrales photovoltaïques
produisent l’équivalent
en consommation électrique
hors chauffage, de 240 foyers.
Avec un autre collectif citoyen voisin,
nous coconstruisons le premier parc
éolien citoyen en Auvergne.
Ces projets d’énergie renouvelable
citoyenne sont fondés
sur l’intérêt commun.
Tout d’abord,
grâce à une gouvernance locale,
on reprend le contrôle de l’énergie
dans l’intérêt du territoire
et de ses habitants.
Et on décide de ce qu’on fait chez nous,
car les projets que nous réalisons
sont tous bâtis
sur une charte portant des valeurs
environnementales et sociétales fortes.
La force d'un collectif citoyen, c'est
d'être à la fois un lieu de propositions,
une force de transformation
vers l’extérieur,
mais aussi un espace
de transformation personnelle.
Il permet à chaque membre du groupe
de pouvoir monter en compétence
sur les sujets liés au projet
que nous réalisons.
Quel impact Combrailles durables
pourrait-il y avoir d’ici 2030 ?
Je dirais que ce collectif citoyen,
qui puise ses racines dans une nouvelle
façon d’être et d’agir ensemble,
doit poursuivre l’essaimage de
sa démarche sur d’autres territoires.
Et nous sommes déjà très fiers
d’avoir contribué à l’émergence
de deux collectifs citoyens
de production d’énergies renouvelables,
du côté de Vichy et d’Ambert.
Un autre impact serait que les
collectivités s’impliquent de plus en plus
dans ces projets à gouvernance locale
de production d’énergies renouvelables.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)